so getting into the flash sins of the
father this really brings us to a
Prelude really the the Prelude to the
button now the cool thing about this is
that in terms of being a Prelude it's
one of several within the realm of of DC
rebirth so far there's been like an
actual essential reading Prelude which
if you guys are down with like the
essential reading Concepts uh Joel over
cable does like essential reading words
like here are the things that you need
to read in order to understand what's
going on with something which uh I
actually use Joel's essential reading
from time to time uh if I'm not sure
where to start with a character so so I
don't know if Benny does it but I do
that from time to time um but the other
half of this is that you know this this
really kind of gives us the the tried
and true uh prelude for the most part if
all you want to do is read the button
and all you want to know is what you
need to read in order to read the button
in order to understand the button well
then you've got DC Universe rebirth
number one and this and that's really it
but for me I like the little tidbits the
little goodies that we get you know
throughout DC Universe rebirth so I
would say there's like a handful of
issues with Superman and there's some
action comic stuff and there's some
Batman stuff I don't have a playlist
this will basically have all the things
that we need in order to understand
what's going on you know for example
Trinity number eight Superman aftermath
uh or Superman reborn aftermath deals
with the Fallout of the whole thing Mr
Oz and all that kind of good stuff but
in terms of just focusing on the button
and the Batman's uh flash landscape it's
just DC Universe rebirth number one and
this and then the Batman Detective
Comics and the Flash comics and that's
that's really it but one thing to keep
in mind is this story really comes out
of the DC rebirth flash story which is
basically flash of Two Worlds you know
Wally West of Two Earths and what this
was or at least what this did is it
basically gave us the idea that Daniel
West was the father of the new 52 Wally
West now the reason why this matters is
because ever since this Revelation took
place it's been on the mind of Wally
Non-Stop and it even reflects the dreams
that he has right like this dream that
he's having right now where he's talking
to Daniel Daniel says look you need to
study you need to stay in school you
need to focus on your education because
if you don't you know you're going to be
like me you're going to become a killer
just like me now the reason why this is
so important is because not only is this
revelation of Daniel West being the
father of Wally West always on the mind
of Wally but Daniel was a guy who gained
speed force powers and then became a
villain now in truth the way that
Daniel's character was written was
always designed to be in such a way that
it would send him down this path and
that was one of the things that a lot of
fans found kind of weird and and really
one of those things that kind of
alienated some fans of of the
traditional reverse flash wolf and what
I mean by that is that if you walk up to
almost any flash fan and you say who who
do you think the best reverse flash is I
would say and this is really me just
kind of spitballing and ballparking nine
like eight or nine out of 10 will say
eobard Thon that's the definitive
reverse flash it's the one they think of
it's the one that was basically
reimagined under the writing of Mark
Wade and the post crisis on infinite
Earth's landscape is the guy who came
from the 25th Century and just got
revenge or you know became a villain of
Barry Allen it's the one that Jeff Johns
basically reworked when we when we
learned that eobard Thon had basically
engineered all the events that led to
Barry Allen becoming the flash in the
first place uh it's Barry's mortal enemy
and so because of all that development
because of the great little moments that
we got and Flash Point different things
like that at the end of the day it was
really just earbud Thon being solidified
as the definitive reverse flash the
problem with this is that when New 52
was launched as good as a lot of The
Flash stuff was when the new 52 was
launched and Daniel West was introduced
as a guy who basically just gained you
know gained speed force Powers you know
after surviving an explosion you know he
wasn't really as fast as Barry but he
was still basically a villain the issue
with this is that the weight was done by
Francis manifold I believe was the one
that wrote it at the time was it was
designed to juxtapose the story of Barry
Allen with Daniel West in the sense that
where Barry Allen's pass was Han pit or
really his life was haunted by the death
of his mother when he was young at the
hands of eobard Thon Daniel West was
haunted by the fact that his father was
abusive and his goal was to go into the
past and kill his father but the string
that tied Daniel Wesson buried together
was the idea that a parent was going to
die a parent in their past was going to
die but again fans didn't really care
for this they didn't really like it and
so for the most part Daniel West was
relatively short-lived you know he was
the reverse flash and then fans were
like nope give us eobard phone or
Nothing at All and so the result was
that Daniel West really just kind of
fell into the background in a lot of
different ways now with regards to this
little bit here with Wally gaining the
powers of the flash during the whole
lightning strikes twice as Trice event
the idea here was that he was afraid
that he would become Daniel West he
would become his father and so because
of this in these little moments you know
this breakfast for example that's shared
between uh Barry and his father and Iris
really haunts Wally West because of the
fact that he looks at the the jokes and
he looks at the laughs that Barry has
with his dad and knows that he can never
experience that now this is what's also
kind of interesting here is because it
is Joshua Williamson basically saying
that Barry and Wally aren't that far
removed right I mean Barry shares these
moments with his dad because he's
basically playing catch-up for almost
the entirety of his of his life you know
from his childhood going into his adult
life his father was essentially framed
for a murder that he didn't commit you
know his father was the one that was
more or less forced to take the rap of
the death of Nora Allen Barry's mother
when reverse flash eobard Thon went back
in time and killed her and so because of
this uh Barry's never really had time or
had a chance to spend these kind of
moments with his dad with Wally it's
similar his father was a bad guy his
father was presumably killed or at least
seems to have been killed at the very
least just vanished off the radar as
follows as far as Wally knows at the
moment and so because of that he's
basically wanting to experience these
same moments that you know that Barry
experiences with his father that's
what's kind of cool about this is
because we've all had those moments
right you know like like you're you're a
single person a single guy or a single
girl and you see couples laughing and
carrying on or something like that and
you want that or maybe you lost a parent
when you were younger and you see other
people spending time with their parents
and you want that or God forbid you're a
parent who lost a kid and you're in the
same boat uh people experience all these
different kinds of situations where they
say I wish I had that too and it's cool
because it allows those people who come
from that kind of experience to identify
with what Wally's doing and that's why I
love the way Joshua Williamson is
basically reworking the new 52 Wally
West because instead of just being this
young angsty kid who's angry because the
world doesn't understand him instead
he's now a kid who's trying to find his
dad and that's the coolest thing about
this is because it makes it more
visceral makes it more real and makes it
more personal and so again it's really
cool to kind of see how this unfolds but
the fact remains here because these
moments are being shared Wally West
effectively just runs now the reason why
Joshua Williamson does this the reason
why he injects these little moments
where Wally West can't really cope with
the situation just takes off running
it's for a couple reasons the first is
because within the story it gives Wally
the ability to clear his head to
basically just kind of sit down and say
look I need to think things over I need
to mull things over I can just run
around the planet a couple times and be
okay outside of the story what is Joshua
Williamson doing is basically saying
we're going to be expanding Wally West
Powers because the ability of a person
to run faster to be able to do things
that they wouldn't normally be able to
do when they first become a flash is
like a muscle right you know the more
you do curls the more you do preacher
curls the more you do bench presses the
more you do squats the more you do these
exercises the stronger your muscles get
you get these muscles built much the
same way that Wally West expands on his
powers the more he uses them he becomes
more in tune with his ability to become
a flash so it's really subtly just kind
of Joshua Williamson you know saying Hey
look this is how Wally's growing in his
abilities now ultimately what we end up
learning here is that Wally had done
some investigation on his own with
regards to the fate of Daniel West and
what he had Learned was that Daniel West
had basically been imprisoned at iron
Heights and then had been transferred
from Iron Heights to belreath
Penitentiary now as soon as Barry hears
that Daniel West is in Bell Reef he
begins to freak out and the reason why
is because we as comic readers know that
Bell Reeve is the last stop man
Bellerive is where people go when
they've been Shanghai into the suicide
squad and so because of that Barry
Allen's initial thought is oh my God
Daniel West is now part of the suicide
squad so because of this you know he and
Wally basically race soft but this is
Joshua Williamson taking things in a
different approach right like we would
expect Barry and Wally just kind of race
in and then look around figure out
there's nothing there and then race out
and they'd be there for maybe two or
three seconds and nobody would have any
idea what's going on but what Williamson
does is he draws on the Justice League
versus Suicide Squad he says no no no
like this is not just some military base
it's not just some building some office
building somewhere this is the base of
operations for Amanda Waller and The
Suicide Squad every precaution that can
be taken has been taken and that's the
coolest thing is because Barry says we
can't just run in now he doesn't tell
Wally why he just says we can't run in
we have to be smart because if anybody
knows that we're here we're immediately
going to be caught and that's true
Amanda Waller would immediately know
that they're there and would immediately
kick in safeguards now the cool thing
about this is that that still happens
and as Joshua Williamson showing us just
how capable Amanda Waller is and that's
why I love her character so much is
because she's she's prepared for almost
every eventuality and she will do
whatever it takes to make sure that she
comes out on top even if it means
killing everybody around her the other
funny part about this is that where
these different guards show up and try
to take out Flash and uh or try to take
out Barry Allen and Wally Wally and
Barry are able to take them out but then
Wally gets a little cocky he's like man
why are you worried about These Guys
these are robots man they're dudes and
metal suits like they're nothing to
worry about and Barry's like yeah
they're nothing to worry about she is
something to worry about enter I'm
Amanda Waller and that's what's crazy is
because we know that Amanda Waller would
make no bones about snatching up Barry
Allen and Wally West and throwing them
into the suicide squad now in truth it
probably wouldn't last for very long I
mean I have a hard time believing that
Amanda Waller could force Barry Allen to
do anything but it's possible it could
be done Barry Allen knows this and he
doesn't really say it in so many words
but he's like look if Amanda Waller so
chose she could find a way to neutralize
my Powers Maybe not today maybe not
tomorrow but in a couple weeks or in a
few months you know I'll be coming out
of a store or something like that I'll
be you know coming out of work as Barry
Allen and then suddenly everything goes
black I wake up in a room somewhere
Shackled unable to vibrate through
anything and Amanda Waller says welcome
to the suicide squad so you know it's
entirely possible that somebody like
that could happen and with that in mind
very is kind of playing the double role
right like he doesn't want Wally to know
what it is that Amanda Waller is
actually doing because if Wally came to
the realization that Daniel West had
been inducted or been forced onto a team
that literally just goes through suicide
side missions and the person sending him
on those missions doesn't care whether
he lives or dies it would crush Wally
and so because that theory doesn't
actually reference The Suicide Squad he
just says hey look if he's part of your
little project you know then there's
going to be held of hay but of course
Amanda Waller being as dubious and being
as full of lies as she is is basically
look I don't know what you're talking
about there's nobody named Daniel West
here now she's actually telling the
truth but she's not telling the whole
truth and we'll find out what the whole
truth is I hear in a little bit but with
Barry and Wally basically leaving again
Wally asked the question what project
are you talking about what is it that
they do here and Barry's like well we'll
talk about that another time but if
Daniel West was part of Amanda Amanda
Waller's project there's a guy who will
know and so what we do is we actually
jump back to the jump to the Australian
Outback with Digger Harkness now this is
cool because this is Joshua Williamson
showing us we're really kind of
expanding on how the suicide squad
functions in a lot of ways now remember
this is DC rebirth so a lot of this is
new to a lot of different people and one
of the things that people think of when
they think of the suicide squad is they
just they just you know they just come
man guns blazing you know I mean I just
start just shooting everything up but
for the most part what what Joshua
Williamson establishes here is that it's
not always that way the suicide squad is
clandestine Espionage first shoot
everything all the pieces second Digger
Harkness is kind of an extension of that
like it's basically a you know Amanda
Waller saying hey look there is a group
operating out of Australia called the
Weaver Clan we have reason to believe
they're developing weapons or they're in
possession of weapons that can
neutralize people with superpowers go
there infiltrate them find out if they
have something if they have nothing say
they have nothing come back your
mission's done if they have something
make their something our something and
then kill them but what ends up
happening here is that while uh diggers
asking questions and trying to
infiltrate the Weaver Clan Barry and
Wally show up out of nowhere so they
kind of throw a kink you know throw a
kink in his plans and and so on leading
to the three of them being captured by
the Weaver Clan proper now the funny
thing about this is that uh Joshua
Williamson kind of toys with us a little
bit like he plays it fast and loose
right he's just gonna like hey like the
the Weaver Clan have like this web that
just neutralizes various ability to
phase through objects and Wally West
can't face the thing either and you know
of course signal hardness just throws
boomerangs so they're all basically
prisoner
storytelling so it's it's kind of cool I
mean I I liked it you know I I thought
it was a great little influx because
when it comes to comic books it's
locking a knife sets telling us stories
uh whenever you're telling a story in
comics there is such a thing as just
giving everybody everything right like
there has to be some measure of just us
figuring things out on our own all right
we'll talk about you know talk a little
bit more about that when it comes to uh
the ending of this story but uh there's
also the idea of not leaving everything
ambiguous and making people feel like
they don't understand anything that's
going on and so because of that you know
it's just kind of fun it's a little bit
of fun here well for whatever reason
they have you know this weird webbing
that vibrates at a frequency that Barry
Allen can't vibrate through you know and
Wally West doesn't know how to vibrate
through things and Digger hardness is
just a guy so they're all pretty much
just held captive and it works you know
for what it is now of course what this
does is it leads into uh just a quick
little bit of Storytelling and a little
bit of of Williamson just kind of
killing time in terms of of filling out
this comic uh what we end up having here
is the Weaver Clan freeing Barry Allen
and Digger Hartness of course Digger
basically saying hey look if your
weapons are as solid as you say they are
then like kill the flash right if your
weapons can kill the flash imagine the
marketing that you'll get hey guys we
have guns that kill the flash the
fastest man alive don't you want to buy
them and then people will just line up
to buy those weapons right because of
that uh it basically allows you know
Barry and and Digger to just kind of run
around and you know for the the Weaver
Clan to kind of shoot at them and prove
their weapons can hit the fastest man
alive but it all serves as a distraction
because with Wally West he's not able to
vibrate through things simply because of
the fact that when he tries he ends up
blowing stuff up and so when he does try
to vibrate he ends up destroying the
bonds and then takes out these members
of the Weaver Clan so coming to the
rescue of Barry and Digger they're able
to take out the Weaver Clan and that's
really the end of that I mean it's not a
great big huge drawn out thing it's not
like the Weaver Clan will be back it's
nothing like that you know they're just
taking prisoner and that's the end of
them and so because of that uh we end up
having you know a conversation between
Digger and Wally you know Wally
basically says hey look you know Daniel
West is my and I just want to know what
happened to my dad now this is cool
because this is Williamson basically
saying hey look you know Digger Harkness
is a guy that throws like really sharp
boomerangs and he's kind of cool
depending on you know what kind of
characters you like but he's also a
human at the same time and with his own
backstory and his own experiences he
feels where Wally's coming from and so
what he basically says is look as far as
I know here's what happened and so what
we're basically told is that the suicide
squad were set on a mission Daniel West
basically ended up running a bomb into
the ocean and then died in the explosion
now there's a little more to it than
this this was covered in Suicide Squad
annual number one and what had actually
happened here is that in the midst of a
Suicide Squad Mission under normal
circumstances Amanda Waller cares
nothing about bystanders if bystanders
die and let him die so long as the
mission is completed Daniel West was
constantly on this path trying to redeem
himself the last holdout was the fact
that in his own origin story when he
wanted to go back in time and kill his
abusive father he kept arguing that was
what he was wanting to do he made the
right call but in terms of a traditional
villain as we knew him was basically
becoming a better person and so this was
like the restorative act this was
basically him uh trying to become a good
guy restoring people's view of him in
terms of being a legit person and so
what ended up happening here is there
was a bomb that threatened to destroy a
village and Daniel raced the bomb into
the ocean so that it would it would
detonate him safely away from everybody
else but was basically sucked into the
Vortex when he tripped and fell in his
attempt to get away now the reason why
this happened was because of the fact
that Daniel just was not as fast as
Barry Allen that's why he wasn't able to
get away as fast as Barry Allen would
have the result was that the explosion
took place in such a way that we saw
like a charred skeletal hand and the
implication was that Daniel West was
dead now this is DC basically toying
with the idea of well maybe he'll come
back and it's really just going through
and sampling things if fans want to see
Daniel West return the possibilities
there DC can make the case and say well
he can't run as fast as the flash so we
can't heal as fast as the flash so he
was basically just healing this entire
time and now he's back or it could
simply just be the fans don't want him
there and they're like yeah no Daniel
West is dead he died in that explosion
in Suicide Squad when anyone number one
you remember that I mean that would be
it you know and so again it allows DC to
kind of go both ways which is a really
smart way to play it the problem is that
with with Wally learning that his father
has effectively been killed um he
immediately just races off now this is a
really great moment a really great
exchange between Wally and Barry simply
because of the fact that Wally basically
asks the question at the heart of
everything he basically says look you
know I idolized my father I idolized
Daniel West I wanted to be like him I
wanted to be fast I wanted to be what I
thought a hero was but the one question
that he wants to know more than anything
anything else is why didn't he want to
be my father and is it because there's
something wrong with me this is Wally
West with abandonment issues that's all
that is it's a son that feels abandoned
by his father and it humanizes Wally
West so well but what ends up happening
here is Barry says look there's nothing
wrong with you and reveals his identity
now this is kind of interesting because
earlier essentially what had happened
was Barry in a discussion with his
father during breakfast before Wally
West had taken off his father said look
you should tell Wally and you should
tell Iris that you're the flash they
need to know they need to be able to
trust you and this would be the ultimate
demonstration of trust to reveal to them
your own identity now of course Barry's
response to this was always no no no
because if somebody knows you know
realizes that they know who I am well
then suddenly their motive shifts away
from well I'm gonna take you captive and
hold you Ransom so that I can get to the
flash instead they'll just say well I'm
just gonna torture you until you tell me
the identity of the Flash and then I'll
kill you and so because of that it puts
them in a much higher level of danger
the other half of this is that Barry
basically runs over the entirety of his
origin with Wally West and of course we
don't really need to run over that we
have that new origin of very already
covered here on my channel but but again
it's very trying to create trust with
Wally the problem is that Wally's
response is you're a liar you are a liar
and you are a chief if you really really
loved Iris if you really cared about me
you would have trusted us you would have
given us this information you would have
said these are two people that I can
trust and it makes sense because for
God's sake Wally and Flash were running
side by side if anything it would create
a stronger friendship between the two of
them if Barry did reveal his identity to
Wally West but at the same time there's
also Merit to the argument that Barry's
making because Wally West does not have
full control of his abilities Wally West
is nowhere near as fast as Barry Allen
he's just not there yet he will be but
he's just not there yet and so because
of that if somebody got a hold of Wally
because while he's young because he's
rashed because he's impulsive if he let
the moment get the better of him which
we've seen it happen well then suddenly
they start torturing him for the
information for the for the identity of
Barry Allen and so because of that you
know Barry's basically trying to play
the Smart Road he was trying to make the
smart decision here and so what ends up
happening is we actually jump back to
iron Heights Penitentiary and the
indication here is that we basically
just have the arrival of eobard Thon now
the idea here or the implication here
seems to be that eobard Thon basically
breaks free of the cell that he was
being confined in or the suit that he
was being held in we're not told
explicitly how that happens where
somebody just told that it happens but
he basically says that he remembers the
whole idea of Thomas Wayne killing him
during the events of Flashpoint and that
he's going to get his revenge on Bruce
Wayne now this is kind of an interesting
scenario in the realm of comics and this
is where we sort of reference the whole
idea of the tightrope again you know
this goes directly into like it
literally segues directly into Batman
number 21 but with regards to this whole
tightrope of of Storytelling this
version of eobard Thon the question is
is why does he remember Flashpoint you
know does he remember things before
Flashpoint and so the whole notion here
is in terms of him being here in this
moment the fact that he was dead that
he's returned is Joshua Williamson
saying time travel any of our thought go
hand in hand for the same reason that
eobard Thon is destined for all eternity
to travel into the past and kill Nora
Allen setting in motion the events for
Barry to become become the flash this is
always going to happen he's always going
to show up here now he's always going to
be in the present everywhere that he's
appeared in the realm of DC Comics will
always happen that will always take
place because in the future he travels
into the past so again it's really kind
of crazy in terms of how it all unfolds
but the idea here is that again this
just goes directly into the whole uh
Batman number 21 and into the button
event itself
okay Rob core we're gonna be dangerous
we're gonna be dangerous some of you
might love me some of you might hate me
we're gonna do the button but we're
gonna do one video for each of the
comics so one and two come out today and
then three and four should come out uh
later on this week probably Thursday
maybe Wednesday I'm not sure but uh
we're gonna try this and we're gonna see
what happens because there's only four
issues it's not like it's six so it's
not like it's gonna take us you know
days to do it'll take us a couple days
and so I figured we'd go ahead and give
it a shot but the button oh my god dude
this story is so good it's one of the
most anticipated stories I've been
looking forward to it for a long time
but I think it's one of the most
anticipated stories of DC rebirth
because this finally gives us some
measure of answering the question what's
going on with the button now for those
of you guys who are just now joining the
DC Comics landscape because the button's
really kind of a big talking point among
the comic book Community we don't know
anything that's going on all we know is
that in DC Universe rebirth number one
when the button that previously belonged
to the comedian before he died in the
Watchman Comics suddenly appeared in the
Batcave it's set in most nothing but
speculation about the Watchman about
what was going on we had this enigmatic
Guy Mr Oz who was talking about people
that are in the New 52 universe that
shouldn't be there about how things are
screwed up and so on and so forth but we
literally know nothing about what's
going on the only thing that this has
given us is the idea that in some form
or fashion The Watchmen are being folded
into the DC Universe and so the idea
that people had is that maybe it was Dr
Manhattan who had messed with all these
things that according to Wally West
somebody took 10 years away from
everybody's life and we didn't know who
it was so maybe it was Manhattan maybe
it was you know at least if you're Sal
over a comic pop you believe that Mr Oz
is the pre-new 52 Lex Luthor which I
love that idea uh but it's just it's
speculation reigning Supreme which is
really half the fun but the button thing
is is so cool this story is so amazing
so um initially we pick up with Saturn
girl Saturn girl is part of the Legion
of Superheroes they're superheroes from
the 31st Century they're from the future
now all we really know about her in
terms of the DC landscape is that in DC
Universe rebirth number one in Batman
number 9 or Batman rebirth 109 and in
this story we've seen her in Arkham
Asylum we don't know why she's there we
don't know who put her there it seems
like she's there against her will we
have no idea what's going on all we know
is that she's there but it's so ironic
that she's in a home for the mentally
insane because Saturn girl being from
the future would likely know how these
events are going to play out now again
this deals a little bit in terms of like
retcons and stuff like that because
non-comic readers would ask the question
although she knew this was going to play
out then why didn't she tell anybody
about it before well because this is a
new introduction to Comics so again
somebody's kind of messing with things
but the fact remains here it's like a
ripple effect or it's like a scar effect
right like like if time were linear all
right there were no alternate realities
or anything like that if I go back to
you and I meet you when you're five
years old and I cut your hand then at 50
years old when I went back in time in
the first place you would suddenly see a
scar appear on your hand out of nowhere
alright it's just basically the fact
that the past influences the future and
so because of that you know most likely
we would have to believe that if she's
from the 31st Century that her memories
would automatically be updated to
reflect whatever it is that's going to
happen with regards to the Watchmen now
we know that she has an understanding of
the future because of the fact that
she's watching a hockey game unfold and
in this hockey game one of the players
gets killed but no one comes and saves
him there's a Superman No Justice League
no nothing it's just a guy dies during a
hockey game but the reason why this is
introduced is because it is Tom Kane
basically kind of throwing in this whole
idea of allowing The Narrative of the
story to be reflected by the hockey game
because with the narrative at least with
the broadcast as it's given to us it's
okay here's the opening Salvo like the
puck is down the players are playing you
know and they start kind of going back
and forth all right let's pass the puck
to this guy pass the puck to that guy
the puck representing information
speculation the idea of what's going to
happen the knowledge of what this button
represents this kind of going back and
forth but the hockey team also
represents players in the DC Universe
superheroes the Justice League so on and
so forth the opposing team perhaps even
the Watchman and so it was kind of cool
to see this unfold because what ends up
happening or at least you know when we
initially saw Saturn girl she was
screaming about how people were going to
die the Legion of Superheroes was going
to die DC's main superhero teams were
gonna die everybody was gonna die and no
one could do anything to stop it and so
the indication seems to be here that
like the home hockey team going against
the the opposing hockey team the home
guys are the superheroes the opposing
team is the Watchman or Dr Manhattan or
whatever they happen to represent and
the home superheroes are getting
obliterated and somebody significant is
going to die now of course this entire
time Batman's really just kind of
meddling around and messing around with
a button that belonged to the comedian
but the crazy thing about this is that
while messing with the button it
suddenly has this interaction with the
mask of psycho pirate now this is one of
the reasons that I'm really glad we
covered Batman rebirth you know when
with all the different stories and
things like that and you'll find that
playlist down in the description because
this is going to go in the Watchman
playlist but inside that playlist we
also have everything from you know
before Watchmen or at least all the
videos we've done before Watchmen as
well as the whole discussion about you
know Batman and Flash and so on and so
forth but the fact remains here with the
psycho pirates mask it's not really the
psycho Pirate's mask so much as it's
called the Medusa mask and what it does
is it basically manipulates the emotions
of others by reflecting its own face so
the Medusa mask will take on the face of
sadness and that individual who's
looking upon the Medusa mask will feel
Sadness the same thing with happiness
anger you know remorse so on and so
forth compassion that whole thing and so
because of that the button reacting with
the mask results in Bruce Wayne seeing
his father Thomas Wayne from the
flashpoint universe and that's why
things are so crazy now if you're new
and you never saw my Flashpoint videos
you'll find those on the playlist as
well everything that you need to
understand what's going on right now is
in that playlist so all you gotta do is
go there click play and you'll be caught
up but assuming that you don't really
have the chance to do that or you don't
really have a whole lot of time the
flashpoint Universe was a byproduct of
Barry Allen remember the flashpoint
universe is basically what initiated the
new 52. very Allen went back in time to
save his mom's life and was successful
in doing so but because of the fact that
she survived and because Barry Allen
essentially never became the flash the
motivation for him being the flash never
existed ultimately it led to him just
being a normal human being but it also
spawned a wholly different universe that
saw a very dark scenario we ended up
saying that the atlanteans and the
Amazons ended up going to war with one
another Superman never became Superman
he landed he was discovered by the US
government and he was held underground
in stasis for almost his entire life one
of the most significant developments in
the flashpoint Universe was that instead
of Bruce Wayne's parents dying having
been shot to death instead Bruce Wayne
was killed his father became Batman and
his mother became the Joker and so it
was so cool it was so awesome such an
amazing piece of Storytelling for us to
be able to see but this illusion is
basically Batman seeing his father as he
existed in the flashpoint Universe now
of course that begs the question of all
the ways in which he could Envision his
father why is he seeing the flashpoint
version you would think that if it was a
hallucination he would think that his
father in his Mind's Eye manifested in a
physical form it would happen by way of
him seeing his father as he remembers
him so again it's basically King telling
us not everything you're seeing is the
way you would expect it to see and
there's a lot more at play here and so
of course what is up happening and this
is when we get to the one one minute
window when everything happens in the
span of one minute Bruce Wayne contacts
The Flash says hey this button that
we've been looking at it had a reaction
to Psycho Pirate's Medusa mask I need
you to get over here so we can analyze
it and we can see what's going on the
flash says okay I'm dealing with these
bad guys I'll be over there the clock
starts one minute from the time this
clock starts until the time we get to
the end of this comic everything takes
place in the span of one minute and the
craziest thing about this is that
immediately almost immediately after
this conversation ends Batman hangs up
he ends up seeing a spark of lightning
his thought is that it's Barry Allen and
it's not it's eobard Thon the reverse
flash now one of the big questions that
a lot of current flash readers are going
to have is how is this eobard Thon
eobard Thon is locked up in Iron Heights
we saw that in the flash store he's
currently in prison his current version
is in prison one of the craziest things
when it comes to earbard Thon is he is
intrinsically tied into time travel and
so while the present-day eobard Thon is
stuck in prison in three hours or five
hours or three days or five days or a
month or even you know 15 years from now
he ends up getting free somewhere along
the line we don't know how and it's not
really important what we know is that
this is eobard Thon being here from at
some point in the past or possibly even
in the in the future and so iob art Thon
because of how he exists because he's so
immersed in trying travel it's entirely
possible for him to exist in two places
at the same time and so what is up
happening here is that he starts talking
to Batman about how a greater power had
called out to him it had basically
reached out to him and he was
essentially resurrected and so the funny
thing about this is Batman faces off
against you know eobard Thon as best he
can but he doesn't stand a chance I mean
eobard Thon is a struggle for Barry
Allen to beat and Barry Allen is wildly
powerful in terms of you know his speed
and capabilities and so on and so forth
dare I say one of the most powerful
members of the Justice League Batman's
just a guy with resources and stuff but
being caught off guard being hit five
six seven times in the span of a second
makes it virtually impossible for him to
provide any kind of counter punch any
kind of offer to what it is that
earbardathon is doing now what ends up
happening is that eobarthon actually
discovers the letter that Batman
received from his father and that was a
part of the flashpoint story when the
flashpoint story began to come to an end
uh Thomas Wayne had basically written a
note for his son and given and gave it
to Barry Allen the reason being because
of the fact that Barry Allen when he met
Thomas Wayne as Batman in the flashpoint
Universe said hey look this is not how
things are supposed to be and the
universe that I come from you and your
wife died and your son became Batman and
so the result is that Thomas wrote a
letter to his son he gave it to Barry
Allen Barry Allen went back in time
stopped himself from saving his mother's
life things more or less went back to
normal but resulted in the new 52 reboot
but at the end of Flashpoint he gave
Thomas Wayne's note to Bruce Wayne and
for one of the only times in the history
of DC Comics Bruce Wayne cried it was an
emotional moment it was really probably
the best possible ending to that story
it was it was insanely well done but in
the midst of all this earbard Thon more
or less kind of makes fun of Batman and
then just rips it all up now eobard Thon
starts saying things like you know did
it make you feel better Thomas and
things like that the reason why is
because of the fact that within the
flashpoint Universe eobard Thon was
there eobard Thon taunted Barry Allen
you know eobard Thon and Barry kind of
went hand in hand in that particular
story again we're leaving a little bit
out here in terms of Flashpoint but of
course like I said we have those videos
you're welcome to go back and watch them
and get the full impact of the story
itself and so earbardvan knew who Thomas
Wayne was mostly because of the fact
that Thomas Wayne was the one that
killed him so
because of that he's pretty he's pretty
aware of who Thomas Wayne is but the
fact remains here that Batman having a
letter from his father ripped to pieces
and thrown away is crushing I mean it's
absolutely crushing for him because it's
the last connection he had to his dad
the last connection that he had to him
now of course Batman seizes the
opportunity to basically you know stab
eobard Thon in the foot and just kind of
keep him pinned to the ground and then
just beat him up a little bit but
ultimately what we end up finding out is
the whole purpose of Batman fighting
against the eobard Thon was to serve as
a distraction the distraction being what
was supposed to be the arrival of Barry
Allen the problem with this is that in
the middle of this whole thing eobard
Thon picks up the button and vanishes
disappears returns and then probably the
greatest points one of the greatest
points in this whole story he starts
freaking out about how he saw God he's
like I saw God and he just starts losing
his mind and then just sort of explodes
in this massive you know melting
deterioration of speech Force lightning
and then Barry Allen simply just shows
up after it's all said and done keep in
mind from the time this this comic
started to the time this comic finished
it's maybe been five minutes maybe five
minutes probably more along the lines of
like three or four but it is so cool to
see this happen because Barry Allen
suddenly gets here and he's like what in
the hell happened like what one minute
you call me and the next eobard Thon is
laying dead and you're you're Clinging
On to dear life and so now the question
becomes who killed reverse flash what in
the world happened
oh my God Rob core man let me tell you
something man I'm chase them now this
story is amazing now let me tell you
something man okay okay dude this this
story man this comic's an emotional
roller coaster like it is just it is so
good oh my God it's some of the best
stories man if God was writing Comics
right now is what it would look like
right now it is it's so good
okay okay so let's let's let's get into
this all right let's let's let's talk
about this so what we end up doing is we
actually kind of go back maybe by about
two or three minutes before Bruce Wayne
and Barry Allen show up in the
flashpoint universe and really what
Thomas Wayne does is just kind of give
us a recount of what it was that
happened in Flashpoint again you guys
are welcome to check those videos out
those videos should keep you abreast of
everything that's going on but the idea
is that we're basically just kind of
told that you know where we initially
thought that the war would end you know
with regards to the death of eobard Thon
with Barry Allen going back in time to
allow his mother to die to keep himself
from saving his mom's life where where
that initially just kind of jump started
the new 52 we were left to believe that
Flashpoint ended that that was just a
pocket Universe the universe was created
when Barry Allen saved his mother's life
and the universe was destroyed when
Barry Allen allowed his mother to die
but what we end up finding out here is
that's not the case Flashpoint kept
going on and it shouldn't have it should
not have gone on at all it should have
stopped it should have ended it should
have just been cut off from a source but
the problem is that it's still floating
out there and not even Thomas Wayne
Knows Why Thomas Wayne's is kind of like
you know this shouldn't be here anymore
the reason for why this universe existed
has basically been undone the universe
should have vanished with it not only
that we end up finding out that because
Flashpoint still exists the war between
the Amazons and the atlanteans just kept
going Aquaman and Wonder Woman are still
at War now eventually they end up
joining forces against Thomas Wayne
himself because of the fact that Thomas
Wayne tried to leave an Insurgency
against them and basically bring them
down but the issue here is that within
his own home within what's left of Wayne
Manor he began planting all different
tons of explosives so that when his
backwards against the wall and there was
no other choice he was going to blow it
all up and take himself with it and at
the moment when he's getting ready to
hit this button The Flash and Batman
show up now this is huge because this is
the first time that Thomas Wayne and
Bruce Wayne meet each other this has
never happened and it's such an
emotional moment between the two of them
because you know remember Barry Allen's
seen all this he's met Thomas Wayne
before he was in the flashpoint Universe
they're not new to him but even Barry
Allen says it shouldn't be this way
things shouldn't be like this this
universe should be gone someone
somewhere is keeping this universe alive
and so again further down the rabbit
hole we're just tumbling down that
rabbit hole alongside Alice because
someone here has so much power somebody
out there presumably Dr Manhattan has so
much power that they can control and
maintain universes as they see fit and
so that's kind of the crazy scenario
here is because what we also end up
having is that where so many questions
are being asked so many things are more
or less being hinted at we end up
finding out that the questions more or
less kind of have to be cut short and
the reason why is because of the fact
that the forces of the Amazons and the
atlanteans are racing down to take out
you know Thomas Wayne and end his
Insurgency and so of course again the
funny thing about this is remember
Thomas Wayne in the the flashpoint
Universe was a lot more ruthless and
violent than Bruce Wayne he did not have
the same kind of restraint and that
worked just because of the fact that
instead of a child losing his parents it
was apparent losing their child and that
has a way of Shifting people in a
fundamental manner that makes them
drastically different than the way they
used to be really it was like Thomas
Wayne looked around he lost his wife who
became the Joker he lost his son who was
murdered there was no reason for him to
even care anymore as though he did
whatever it was that he had to do in
order to try his best to restore some
order to everything that's going on but
not only that for the Batman fan and
indeed even for just like the general
comic book fan we get to see Batman and
his father Thomas Wayne fight alongside
one another and it's so cool to see this
because what we end up doing of course
is we basically have Barry Allen
repairing the cosmic treadmill you know
of course is super speed and that kind
of thing in order to basically get
themselves out of there now at this
point you know once these forces are you
know more or less subdued there's this
really beautiful moment between Batman
and and his father Thomas really Thomas
kind of begins talking to Bruce about
the memories or at least memory that
they mutually share with regards to
their own past experiences now this is
really important and the reason why is
because in the flashpoint stories we
never really got a whole bunch of uh
really in any in-depth analysis in terms
of what the histories of the characters
were like before the events of
Flashpoint in relation to the main DC
Universe all we got was basically hey
here's what led up to the flashpoint
story you know led up to the events in
the flashpoint universe and that was
really about it but what we end up
finding out is that there was a point
where the memories really the the the
timeline of the DC Universe for Thomas
and the flashpoint universe and Bruce in
the main DC Universe were exactly the
same the Divergence was presumably when
Barry Allen never became the Flash and
so because of this you know they end up
talking about a you know when Bruce
Wayne fell down the cave now of course
we don't get super in-depth into this
and instead you know what we end up
finding out is of course you know Thomas
was whispering for the most part because
he didn't want to you know disturb the
bats and kind of cause Panic or anything
like that but in the midst of them
having this conversation getting ready
to basically go about their business
someone presumably just wipes out the
flashpoint universities began the
process of eroding it all now again this
is just a crazy Display of Power I mean
just an astronomical Display of Power
but we still don't know what's going on
and even very kind of hypothesizes on
this was it a singular being out there
who was keeping the universe alive and
chose to go ahead and allow the universe
to die was it almost like they had their
foot on the gas and on the brake and all
they had to do was let off the brake and
that car was just ready to go or is the
universe just kind of wiping out now
it's just one of these things with with
regards to Barry Allen's actions that
when he went when he went back and
allowed his mother to Die the effects of
his actions in basically eliminating the
flashpoint Universe are just now
catching up to things and the universe
is just now beginning to be wiped away
they don't know but the answer to that
question is the implication is that a
stock to Manhattan who's just destroying
that universe but we don't know but in
this last little bit of a conversation
and this is when the story gets so
emotional and this last little bit of a
conversation Bruce Wayne tells his
father Thomas you have a grandson I have
a son named Damien you know you have a
grandson and this is when things begin
to radically shift because Bruce
besieges his father to join them to come
with them to get them out of there and
what ends up happening is Thomas just
kind of pushes him you know onto the
cosmic treadmill and tells the flash to
get him out of there and this is where
really I think the stage is set for the
future of what's gonna happen with the
Batman concept Thomas basically tells
his son stop being Batman you know when
I had you I knew that I'd made all the
right choices because it led me to you
like I know that I made all the right
calls because I had you as a son and
that you're the you're the greatest gift
that I ever could have had but he says
don't be Batman be a father let go of
your anger let go of your pain let go of
your struggle and your Strife let all
that go and just be a man be happy be a
father for your son in the way that I
never could now what this seems to
indicate is that we're gonna see Batman
kind of taking his father's words to
heart and maybe just vacating the
landscape maybe walking away and the
stage is being set in a lot of different
ways for example in Nightwing uh in the
what is it night where you must die
storyline the one that we just covered
Damien Wayne's whole irritation is the
idea that Nightwing will take up the
mantle when Batman retires instead of
Damien himself we know Duke is being
trained for something in particular all
the roads really seem to lead to this
idea that Bruce Wayne is going to vacate
the wall of Batman or maybe he won't
maybe he'll just stay Batman you know
maybe he'll just be like you know I've
got to live up to the legacy of what my
father did and that kind of thing we
don't really know but in these moments
healing these final moments we end up
having this this beautiful segment when
we learned what it was that Thomas said
to his son when Bruce fell down into the
cave and Bruce asked the question why
are you whispering and Thomas said
because we don't want you to disturb the
bats Bruce of course apologized by
saying I'm sorry I fell in the cave his
father responded by saying it's okay
sometimes we fall but remember Wayne's
never stayed down and then like he just
charges headlong into this conflict and
he's like We rise and it's like the
coolest thing because we don't know
what's on the other side of this light
all we know is that something's there
and regardless of what it is Thomas
Wayne is just Fearless the guy goes out
like a hero just runs headlong into
whatever it is that's there presumably
his own death and that's the end of him
and the universe that he resides in and
so it's just this incredibly emotional
moment because it's Thomas Wayne meeting
with his son it's Bruce Wayne meeting
with his father it's the two of them
being able to reconcile and while Thomas
had so many things he wanted to say to
his son the main message was sent across
go find happiness stop living this life
of anger and misery and deceit go be a
happy person stop letting the death of
myself the death of your mother dominate
your life just go live and so while the
question is being asked what in the
world happened we end up having like
eobard Thon racing up behind them now
again this kind of asks the question
where did eobarthon come from he was
supposed to have been dead of course you
know we basically have Batman answering
this question for us so this is ear
barthon before he ended up killed in the
that cave itself and so you know this is
one of those things where ear barthon
can exist essentially in two places at
the same time now we don't know where
he's coming from all he says is that
he's seen who it was that this button
belongs to he knows the power of the
person that this button belongs to he
knows what they're capable of they've
never faced someone like me now this has
huge implications for the story because
what this does is this asks several
possibilities We Know by virtue of the
solicitations for the flash number 22
the fourth part of the story really the
final part of the story that it seems
like Jay Garrick is going to be involved
in some form or fashion whether it's his
return whether it's his debut whatever
the case may be he will be involved in
some way now if earbard Fawn were to
meet Jay Garrick right off the bat he'd
be able to figure out Jay garrish is not
fast enough to keep up with him Jay
Garrett doesn't know about him Jay
Garrix you know just too honorable too
good whatever the case may be but Jay
Garrick has never faced anybody like
eobard Thon that's a possibility it
could be that Ian Thon met one of the
Watchmen maybe he met the comedian
before he died maybe he met Ozymandias
you know and his idea is well hey
they've never faced anybody like me I'm
so dangerous I'm so crazy they'll never
be able to stand against someone like me
maybe he glimpsed the power glimpsed uh
Dr Manhattan you know maybe Dr Manhattan
doing something or just kind of meddling
about his own business any of our Thon
underestimates the power of Dr Manhattan
and simply says Dave never faced anyone
like me before they've never faced
anybody as powerful and as as crazy as
my abilities are I'm just that good at
what I do now in truth that final option
with the whole idea with Dr Manhattan
that is the most logical scenario one
because of how ibarthon reacted freaking
out talking about how he saw God too
because eobard Thon is arrogant enough
to legitimately believe that no one like
Dr Matt hadn't had ever seen a power
like his before and that as fast as he
is and as capable as he is that he could
somehow overpower Dr Manhattan those are
entirely possible ideas but as we know
just by virtue of what we saw in the
second part of the button that does not
work out in his favor that's sure he's
very arrogant that sure he's very cocky
but his actions get the better of him
and iabbard Fawn ultimately dies
Rob core man let me tell you something
man let me chase him now y'all know
what's about to happen
the button yes the button the conclusion
of the button I can't talk too loud
right now because I'm in a hotel room
I'm in Disney World but man let me tell
you something man I would not normally
stop going to Disney World to record
something but I will stop going to
Disney World to record the button man
let me tell you something man if God was
writing DC Comics right now is what it
would look like right now this is some
of the best comic book writing that I've
ever seen that I have ever seen and I've
seen Jonathan Hickman write stuff I am
reading Jeff John's Green Lantern right
now
this is such a good story so in the last
video we had picked up with the idea
that eobard Thon was finally caught up
to by Batman and Barry out on the flash
it was almost like the events were just
gonna Circle right back around to the
beginning right like it was back to the
scene where ear bar Thorne just kind of
showed up in you know the bat cave he
talked to Batman they fought for a
little bit for like the span of you know
one second or something along those
lines uh he disappeared reappeared
ranted about seeing God and then died
this gives us that cool moment and this
is what I love about earbardathon this
is one of the things I love about his
characters ear Bard Thon is like
Fearless right I mean he's arrogant and
he has every right to be this story
confirms exactly what we've been
thinking that eobard Thon is timeless in
every sense of the word eobard Thon as
we see him here is the same eobard Thon
that appeared in the markway stories the
old Mark Wade Flash stories the return
of Barry Allen this is the eobard Thon
from Flashpoint this is the earbard Thon
from flash rebirth before DC rebirth
this is the same eobard thought that
we've been reading for years and years
and years he's arrogant he's coggy and
it works but the crazy thing about all
this is that in this moment it's Barry
Allen trying to reason with him right
like it's Barry Allen trying to say look
dude if you keep down this path you're
going to die but it's the cocky nature
of eobard Thon coming right back to bear
and saying you can't stop me I'm
timeless like I've been killed and I
always come back I am pardon parcel to
the negative speed force I am pardon
parcel to surviving I will always find a
way back and he always does but this is
the one scenario where he can now again
the funny thing about Williamson kind of
hitting back on the idea that this is
the reverse flash that we've known for
so long is when he starts referencing
the things that he did to Barry Allen
going back in time manipulating his life
so that he would become the flash that
was established by Jeff Johns during
flash rebirth when Barry Allen was first
brought back prior to the start of the
new 52 and eventually DC rebirth we have
eobard Thon talking about the idea of
taking Barry Allen going all the way
back to the very early days when he
first became the flash kidnapping him as
a child raising him as his own and
making him an acolyte which begs a
question what would Barry Allen look
like as the reverse flash what kind of
version of Barry Allen would we be
seeing in that particular scenario but
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
there's simply too late you know eobard
Thon arrives to the destination of where
the button was taking him and this is
when we find out kind of who it was that
he saw now the way that Williamson does
this is beautiful it's so beautiful
because all we get is Thon just kind of
talking to this person saying hey look
you remain hidden from everybody no one
knows everything that you've done but
you can reveal yourself to me I'm your
friend you know I can't be killed or
anything like that I'm the one constant
if anybody can understand what it is
that you've done with time it's me give
me the knowledge that you have and this
is kind of funny because Williamson is
playing it fast and loose here because
if you look the indication is that
Manhattan is in the button that ear bar
Thon is literally talking to the button
now we as readers know that it's not
necessarily that way we as readers know
that for the most part this was really
just the button operating as a key of
sorts you know in the sense of somebody
grabs it it takes them to a pre-door
pre-ordained location and they meet Dr
Manhattan and this is exactly what
happened with with iobarthon he meets
Manhattan but he's totally overwhelmed
by the power that he's seeing I mean
this is really kind of DC showing us
where Dr Manhattan stands in the realm
of his capabilities now the funny thing
about this is that along the way we get
this disembodied voice that's basically
saying Barry Allen was the key saving
Wally West Barry Allen can save me too
all he has to do is listen now from the
solicitations when the covers were just
being issued out to everybody the
implication here was that it was Jay
Garrick and the question was going to be
how will we get Jay Garrick back because
keep in mind Jay Garrick hails from
Earth 2. he yells from the age of the
golden age of superheroes that Universe
which is Earth 2 all the original
superheroes from the 1930s 1940s even
some in the early 1950s that's all Earth
too when DC revamped Earth 2 in the new
52 Jay Garrick that we saw then was
nothing like the one that we saw now
totally different completely removed
totally separate from the character we
were used to and so the idea here is
that the Jay Garrick that we knew was
just kind of lost in time now this is
not the first time that DC has done this
remember after crisis on infinite Earth
there was only one universe and so in
order to bring in Alan Scott in order to
bring in Jake Eric those various
characters that had their run in the
Justice Society of America the JSA as it
was written by Jeff Johns they had to
find a way to roll them in into a
universe that didn't have a Multiverse
into one universe that the main DC
heroes resideed in so it looks like
they're going back to that they're
basically saying hey look we've only got
one Universe here I mean Earth two
that's already happened whatever we've
only got one Universe here we have to
find a way to bring Jay Garrick in and
that was my initial response that was my
initial thought and I was hyped to see
that but kind of jumping back here too
to iobard Thon the great thing about
this is that he's just overwhelmed with
power and again this is really just DC
saying here's how powerful Dr Manhattan
is I mean here's just the level of
strength that he has something hitherto
unseen by eobard Thon and you gotta
remember eobard thon's fought everyone
earbard Thon has fought the Justice
League he's fought the flash he's fought
some of the most powerful beings in the
DC Universe and come out on top you know
Heavy Hitters like Superman and so on
and so forth they're nothing to scoff at
the fear that earbard Fawn shows here is
something that we've never seen this is
a childlike expression it's the
realization that he has stepped into
uncharted waters that he's called down
the Beast and the Beast has answered and
it's far more than eobard Thon ever
expected and in light of this he
effectively loses his life now this is
kind of crazy because in this moment
Batman having heard this disembodied
voice of Jay Garrick Barry Allen failing
to pick it up ultimately means that Jay
Garrick makes his presence known when
Barry finally acknowledges the sound of
the voice meaning that the memory of Jay
Garrick is now alive and well and Jay
Garrick survives only through memories
meaning if Barry Allen can grab this
memory and bring it into reality then
Jay Garrick will very much be alive and
this is what we get now the reason why I
love this particular moment in this
comic book is because golden Golden Age
superheroes especially when they're
drawn by Alex Ross they invoke a kind of
emotion this visceral feeling that I can
never Shake every time I see it I've
said it a million times before and I'll
say it a million times again there is
this amazing shot that Alex Ross Drew
where you've got like the superheroes
running towards the screen and you've
got Superman holding the American flag
and he's surrounded by by all these
other Golden Age superheroes and it
reminds you of an era when Superheroes
Were truthful when there was no moral
ambiguity it wasn't well maybe we're
good guys maybe we're bad guys there
were no anti-heroes there were good guys
and there were bad guys the good guys
did the good thing that bad guys did the
bad thing they fought the good guys won
the day was saved and that was it Jay
Garrick is a return to that Jay Garrick
is a return to this era when superheroes
walked a little bit taller you know when
they were a little clear when they just
kind of made you feel hopeful and that's
why Jay Garrick's return here is so
significant the saddest thing about this
is that it's so short lived Jay Garrick
tries to pull the same road that that
Wally West said or Wally West appeared
to Barry Allen said you have to remember
me if you don't remember me I will be
gone I will die that'll be the end of me
of course Barry Allen trying his best is
not able to do it but notice what
happens here notice what takes place
here Jake Eric doesn't really die per se
or at least it doesn't seem to be the
case instead he's just immersed in blue
energy and whisked away and so the indie
education seems to be here that Barry
was going to remember who he was Barry
was going to remember him and say oh
you're Jay Garrick I remember you now
but in that fraction of a second before
it happened Jay Garrick was whisked away
presumably by Dr Manhattan and that begs
the question is Dr Manhattan building
his own Army is he building his own
superheroes his own villains to go
against the traditional DC Superheroes
is that what we're effectively going to
see the Justice Society of America
versus the Justice League of America
with the JLA on the side of good and the
JSA on the side of Dr Manhattan it begs
that question what are we going to see
because I have a hard time believing
that Jay Garrick will be brought back as
popular of a character as he is Among
The Flash family and as many people have
been looking forward towards his return
I have a hard time believing that he
would be brought here and then just
prominently whisked away and that would
be the end of him but what this story
does as it starts to wrap up is it
basically looks at this entire event
from the perspectives of The Flash Barry
Allen and Batman Bruce Wayne from Barry
Allen's ideology he basically says look
this case is far from over this is not
going to stop I'm going to keep trying
to find that you know trying to find out
who this person was that killed earbud
Farm because remember Bruce Wayne and
and you know Barry Allen they don't know
about Dr Manhattan they don't they
didn't see anything that ibarthan saw
they don't know the Manhattans out there
all they know is that some just wildly
powerful force killed Thon and whisked
Away Jay Garrett or at least from their
assumption Jager seems to be dead
basically kind of dissipated and that's
really the end of him but the other
thing here and this is what's so cool
about this is that Batman reflects on
the words of his father where his father
says find happiness do not be Batman go
and be a father to your son leave that
life behind because it will only lead
you down the road of anger and sadness A
Life That's not worth having a life that
you really can't look back on and find
any small measure of Peace in and so in
the moment when the bat signal goes out
and when Alfred asks the question are
you going to respond to that Batman just
kind of drops his head and it looks like
Bruce Wayne will not be Batman is he
quitting is he leaving is Damian Wayne
going to take up the role so many
questions are presented here and so in
this last little bit we have Dr
Manhattan picking up this button and
this is God this is beautiful God this
is
something this is this is gorgeous Dr
Manhattan picking up this button making
this statement about how everything is
preordained Dr Manhattan is a slave to
the time he can't break time he can't
violate time we know that perspective
from before Watchmen Dr Manhattan we
covered that we talked about that you'll
find that link down in the description
Dr Manhattan is like look everything
that I say and do is preordained I can't
break away from time I am I'm as much of
a prisoner of it as anybody else's and
so then the question has to be asked is
Dr Manhattan being altruistic here is he
doing what he believes to be the right
thing and if so where does this road
lead what happens with all of this it
raises more questions than it answers
damn it if this is not one of the best
stories that's ever been written in DC
Comics
excited oh my God man I'm so excited
dude this man I wish y'all could see me
right now man the story man like dude
the ending to this let me tell you
something man eobard Thon man is one of
my favorite villains of all time one of
the best villains that there's ever been
in the history of like any comic book
publication ever he's got so much
character he's got so much Pizzazz he's
got so much of that stuff that's just
like oh man if I could be a bad guy it'd
be him
that's pretty messed up but this follows
the whole idea of the butt right like
this is just the epilogue to the button
leading into a new story Running Scared
but God Heaven if this is not just
freaking Joshua Williamson man let me
tell you something right now man if God
was right in the flash right now that's
what it would look like right now this
is just it's just an amazing it's just
an amazing story all right let's calm
down let's calm down because we spent
like a minute saying pretty much nothing
let's calm down let's relax so the cool
thing about this is that this initially
picks up in the 25th Century right well
Lisa it does to a degree and we get this
sort of back and forth thing now in
terms of like jumping between like
explanations or jumping between points
in time this only really happens twice
it only really happens this time and one
other time but it's designed to mimic
the nature of eobard thought and we'll
get to that here in a second but jumping
back I mean what this really just kind
of does is it actually changes things it
turns them on his head because it goes
through this whole Legacy of all the
different flashes that have ever existed
for example the godspeed uniform is
there which basically tells us that
following the introduction of the speed
force storm across this across the
Central City and Godspeed gaining his
powers that the future was retroactively
affected by what it is that took place
in the past resulting in godspeed and
being introduced to the whole idea of
the flash Mythos but it shows us all
these different iterations Barry Allen
Wally West you know the classic Wally
West the new 52 Wally West all these
different versions but the huge
difference here is that we're basically
told about the character of eobard Thon
and that instead of the two of them
being enemies the two of them are
actually allies or at least that's the
story that's being given to us now this
is cool because remember eobard Thon is
a guy that was obsessed with the concept
of Barry Allen he was obsessed with the
idea of the flash he was never connected
to him he wasn't part of the family line
or anything like that he was just a guy
in the future who was obsessed with the
idea of the flash he basically had
surgery done to make himself look like
Barry Allen he gave himself speed for
Powers he went to the past with the
intention of meeting Barry only to
basically lose his way when he arrived
due to the effects of time travel and
then going through and looking at the
Flash's uh you know Museum coming to the
realization that he was destined to be
the Flash's most notable enemy he had a
psychotic break and the two of them
became two of the most popular foes to
have ever existed in comic books and so
what we do is we follow up with this
little bit of a of a intro here with the
present day picking up with the idea of
Barry Allen now what Joshua Williamson
does here is actually pretty genius
because we know that eobard Thon simply
can't die iobarthon is effectively
Immortal for one of two reasons but the
first is the reason as is explained here
and the second is the nature of eobard
Thon which we'll talk about as we get
you know as we we get further into this
video but with regards to this little
segment here what bariana basically says
is that whoever was that quote unquote
destroyed eobard Thon didn't actually
destroy him instead they basically
slowed him down slowed down his
connection to the you know to the speed
force of the negative speed force in his
case and uh and ultimately it basically
slowed down his healing Factor but his
body's still recovering and that's the
cool thing about this because remember
when it comes to speedsters so long as
they're connected to the speed force
their body will heal and so in the case
of eobard Thon because he's so powerful
because he's the only person that draws
on a negative speed force the sort of
antithesis to the speed force proper
then what it means is that all that
energy basically flows directly into him
and he doesn't really have to share it
with anybody so it's like if Barry Allen
was the only flash that existed the
speed force would flow entirely into him
and nobody else again this is kind of a
necessary thing because if the speed
force were a battery then it's like
having a battery that a phone's charging
off of and a radio is charging off of
and I'm multitude of other things the
more things you have hooked up to that
battery the faster you're gonna drain
its life the speed force is the exact
same way and so with regards to this
whole idea of eobard Thon what it means
is that despite him having been you know
quote unquote killed or at least
presumed to have been killed by Dr
Manhattan uh he was really more just
like incinerated but his body physically
survived and so because his body
physically survived he will simply just
heal now this tells us that in order for
eobard Thon to be destroyed in any one
particular place in time he'd have to
totally incinerate his body but the fact
remains eobard Thon simply cannot die
and the reason why we get into this is
because of the fact that Barry Allen of
course basically had a birthday party
thrown for him by Iris West and the
various members of the you know the
Central City crime labs and I guess STAR
labs and so on and so forth and it's
really just kind of a celebratory thing
but the entire time this is happening
Barry's doing nothing more than just
kind of recollecting on the events of
the button you know this guy with this
weird funky helmet that Barry never you
know doesn't know who he is of course we
know that's Jay Garrick and that's the
coolest thing is because when DC
launched the noon 52 they basically
reinvigorated Earth 2 this alternate
reality with a golden age of superhero
was resided and the reason why that
matters is because in classic DC Earth 2
was eliminated after crisis on infinite
Earth and eventually came back during
Infinite Crisis Jay Garrick was like old
man flash right like he was just this
older guy who just ran not nearly as
fast as Barry Allen but he ran pretty
fast but he brought a kind of wisdom and
a kind of hope to the flash family that
really wasn't available from anybody
else just because he'd been The Flash in
his own Universe for so incredibly long
and Humanity really kind of viewed that
reality's version of superheroes a
little different than they did in the
main DC Universe that if you were to
look for example at like an Alex Ross
rendering of uh Jay Garrick if you feel
some kind of surge of Hope or kind of
this feeling of nostalgia or something
along those lines that's what DC was
always trying to put forward when it
came to the character of uh of Jay
Garrick whether it was in the nature of
the stories that were being told the way
that he was drawn the events as they
were unfolding whenever it is that Jay
Garrick showed up sure he wouldn't be
able to defeat iobarthon but the hope
that he brought with him the Nostalgia
the kind of reinvigoration the hey we
can pull this off that kind of feeling I
was always like the little bit of an
extra extra boost that like Barry or
Wally or somebody needed in order to
basically take on or take out whatever
villain they were facing off against so
it was really kind of a cool thing you
know that's why I always loved him his
old man flash because he's just kind of
this great you know this this great bit
of invigoration here but remember during
the events of DC rebirth with the button
with new 52 Jay Garrick was kind of
rebooted but people didn't really care
for him too much his character was all
right but if they had to choose between
like the classic Jay Garrick or the
modern game you know modern jig Eric
they would choose the classic Jay
Garrick the modern Jay Garrick wasn't
terrible not by any standard of
measurement it wasn't anything like that
it was just kind of a Nostalgia thing
for a lot of older readers and so DC
rebirth was sort of teasing the idea
that Jay Garrick is going to come back
and the way that we know this is because
by the statements that are made in this
particular story when we read the button
we were kind of left to believe that
maybe Jay Garrick was incinerated he was
being held captive somewhere he escaped
just in the nick of time or at least was
able to get out just in the nick of time
to help Barry and uh and Bruce Wayne
escape the time stream and then was
yanked back in again we didn't know if
he was killed we didn't really know what
it was that was going on all we knew was
that much like the classic one while he
was the only way for Jay Garrick to
escape his confinement so to speak was
for Barry Allen to remember who he was
and tether him to the main DC Universe
instead of wherever it was that he was
being held but because Barry couldn't
remember who he was Jay Garrick just
kind of went back to whatever stasis pot
or you know whoever it was was holding
on to him presumably Dr Manhattan but
what this tells us is that Jay Garrick's
not dead he was just taken back to
wherever he was being held from which
means that Jay Garrick will probably
come back somewhere along the line it's
Williamson as DC saying hey guys look
just because Jay Garrick you know showed
up for a second and then vanished
doesn't mean he's gone forever we're not
yanking your chain he's probably gonna
come back somewhere along the line and
what it does is it really kind of
creates this feeling of like yeah like
we're getting this great combination of
the things that we loved and the things
that we love now and kind of being
merged and brought together into one
thing but the other half of this is that
Barry Allen begins to think back on the
idea of iobarthon and this gets into the
second half of our discussion on why
eobard Thon cannot be killed remember
eobard tharn is he's part and parcel to
time travel that's just part of who he
is he comes from the 25th Century in the
25th Century on the day that he gave
himself powers and the day that he made
himself look like Barry Allen and the
day he traveled back in time that's a
fixed construct that's never going to
change it's always going to be that way
I mean I guess Barry could go into the
21st century and kill Fawn but the whole
idea is the fact that Thon is running
around means that he cannot be stopped
from ever becoming the reverse flash
that's always going to happen it's an
immutable concrete aspect of the DC
timeline and because of that no matter
how many times Barry Allen kills eobard
Thon in the future or in the present or
in the past no matter who does anything
to him it's irrelevant eobard Thon will
always pop back up again because he's
always running back and forth through
time so it was almost like there's an
infinite number of versions of him like
there's a version of eobard Thon for
each particular second in time so you
know you kill one this second the one a
second from now will pop back up for
whatever reason it doesn't matter what
it is but it's just this idea that he
will never leave he will always be there
and this is kind of cool because I love
the character of eobard Thon and we'll
we'll find out how awesome he is as we
end up getting you know further through
the story but in the middle of this
whole birthday party everything's kind
of interrupted by a guy by the name of
Danton black now Danton black in this
story is by no means like a major
character right like he's he's a pretty
small time guy I mean the whole idea of
this is that there's a chick named Sally
at this party she and dancing black like
had a drink and Anton is just like we're
in love like it was it was this weird
scenario so he literally shows up here
crashes this party just because he's
chasing after some girl now the other
half of this and something to keep in
mind here is that the party's also
visited by Hal Jordan and that's a cool
thing because Hal Jordan and and you
know really The Flash are kind of
extremely strong friends in a lot of
ways one of the reasons you know Barry
Allen becoming like a blue lantern
different things like that there's a
very rich history between the two
characters both before the new 52 and
during the New 52 and so again focusing
on the idea of Danton black his
character really goes by the name
Multiplex and he was a guy who gained
his powers at least before the new 52
gained his powers in the same way or
really during the same uh explosion that
ended up merging Rodney Raymond and
Martin Stein into the character of
Firestorm and so the result is that he's
like you know Multiple Man Jamie Madrox
from uh from Marvel Comics in the sense
that he can make an infinite number of
copies of himself now the cool thing
about this is that unlike Jamie Madrox
Multiplex is a little more extreme and
is the extreme nature of his character
that makes him so cool because facing
off against Hal Jordan and facing off
against the flash is a pretty difficult
task for a lot of people I mean one
you're talking about a guy who can move
faster than time faster than death
faster than light in the universe at the
same time you're talking about Hal
Jordan the greatest of the Green
Lanterns depending on what fan you're
talking to but a guy whose Green Lantern
ring could have can allow him to achieve
virtually any feat which includes
creating massive you know constructs
they can just round up all these
versions of multiplexes so the idea is
to form like this massive swarm and
that's what makes it so cool because
Multiplex coming after Flash and after
Hal Jordan it's like being attacked by a
swarm of bees each one containing
basically the orders of Multiplex
himself and operating a can you know
akin to what it is that he wants to do
and that's that's what's so cool about
this now of course the other half is New
52 Wally West and Iris West and the
reason why this is cool is because while
she was attending the party alongside
Wally Wally basically you know whisks
her home and says hey look there's this
huge conflict you don't really need to
be here you're just an average person
you'll end up getting yourself hurt but
when they get back to iris's home
they're met by the arrival of eobard
Thon and that's why this is so cool is
because this could happen due to any
number of factors it could very well be
that it's just some version of eobarthon
out there somewhere it could be that
it's eobard Thon who basically healed
himself we're not told which one it is
and eobard Thon makes no reference to
the events of the button which is to say
he makes no reference to the fact that
he was totally obliterated and then
returned so this is presumably some
other version of eobard Thon from a
different point in time that hasn't been
affected yet by the events of the button
because remember with theobard thon's
whole idea of time travel it gets
absolutely Bonkers and so I guess we
could say that what passes for the past
which is to say any version of eobard
Thon that is has not ended up at the
moment where he gets destroyed by Dr
Manhattan could appear at any point in
time this simply seems to be one of
those when it comes to ear barthon it's
it's it's hard to avoid the idea of time
but it's also easy to minimize the
discussion of time and so DC treats time
travel totally different from Marvel
Comics and it can make things absolutely
wild especially when it comes to the
idea of thought trying to keep things
simple here one other thing to keep in
mind is that eobard Thon remembers
everything before the events of
Flashpoint and that's what's so cool
about this is because this entire
discussion this entire conversation he
has with the new 52 Wally West is rooted
in the idea as if eobard Thon had just
walked into the new 52 from classic DC
and so he looks around and he's like I
fought a lot of different versions of
Barry Allen's Protege I've caught
impulse I fought Wally West you know the
classic Wally West Kid Flash you I don't
know who you are and this is interesting
because eobard Thon puts the new 52
Wally West a task and demonstrating what
he can do now he's not doing it in like
a mentor capacity right he's like he's
not like okay kid I'm gonna train you to
be a great flash because I'm a good guy
let's see what you can do it's literally
just eobard Thon testing him by trying
to beat the crap out of him and look at
what's happening I mean look at this
it's not a contest and that's what we
would expect like with the new 52 Wally
West this power is just not there yet
he's just now getting to the point where
he can begin harnessing his power in a
way that he can get relatively close to
controlling it but he's not Barry Allen
and eobard fawn is a chore even for
Barry and so it's just it's night and
day it's it's not a contest in any form
or fashion not only that the other thing
you have to remember about eobard Thon
is that he is cool and he is ruthless
and he's cunning but he's so charismatic
but he just pops you know that's that's
the coolest thing that's the best way I
can describe him he's just so cool
because with efr and Thon it's not a
matter of him setting his sights on you
and saying okay now I'm going to kill
you it doesn't work that way eobard thaw
never just targets a person eobar tharum
targets you and anyone you've ever met
he goes after your livelihood and the
livelihood of every one you've ever
known he just erases you from existence
and so if he goes through the chronology
of your life and he's like okay so you
were born to your parents okay well I
mean I guess we can you know you're
going to be born so we're gonna go ahead
and kill your parents uh you also had a
really good third grade teacher who
helped to make you who you are so we're
gonna kill that person you had a few
girlfriends over the course of your high
school career so we're gonna kill them
uh you fell in love and got married when
you were in college so she's dead now uh
and and that's literally what he does
he's just like we're just gonna kill
them all that's what makes eobard Thon
so crazy is because it's Mind Games it's
Shadow games it's every conceivable role
every conceivable task a person can take
to obliterate a human being from
existence that's exactly what he will do
and so by the time eobard Thon gets goes
to work on it because to quote Ocean's
11 first he'll kill you and then he'll
go to work on you once he's done it'll
be like you never existed no one will
have ever known your name no one will
ever see your face you'll never be there
you'll it'll be like you were just a
person that was never there you know and
that's the craziest thing is because
that's what he does that's what he
attempts to go after now the funny thing
about this is Iris West because remember
this is New 52 Iris West for reasons
that again we can only really chalk up
to the actions of Dr Manhattan we don't
really know what it is Iris West does
not remember anything before the new 52
because remember what DC has been toying
with with the idea of DC rebirth is that
back in 2011 when the new 52 first
launched that it was okay okay here's a
reboot here's new origin stories these
are all brand new lives for all these
characters DC rebirth came back and said
no that's not what happened what
happened is Barry Allen went back in
time initiated Flashpoint tried to fix
it and then after the events of
Flashpoint everybody remembered their
lives all these characters were still
there but then presumably Dr Manhattan
stepped in and said and now all your
minds are white now as far as all of you
guys know you're new Iris West doesn't
know Barry Allen not because of the new
52 reboot but because of the fact that
Dr Manhattan modified her memory so she
would forget that was the whole idea
that's the whole basis behind DC rebirth
now why Dr Manhattan assuming it was him
why he did that we don't know we're
waiting for presumably Doomsday Clock to
tell us which man I'm excited about
dudes like I'm hyped man I'm sorry I'm
super excited but these are the things
that are kind of being fleshed out but
for me about Thon his mind wasn't wiped
he remembers everything he knows
everything that's been happening you
know now we're kind of left to believe
that in the time when he was defeated
you know after the events of Flashpoint
and the time that he re-emerged that's
when Dr Manhattan acted and so
presumably it was you know it's almost
like eobardthan was in a coma and then
everything was changing around him and
he woke up after it was changed
remembering the way everything used to
be and so he doesn't really know what Dr
Manhattan did and if he does he's not
telling anybody and so it's really kind
of interesting here because from his
perspective Iris West the way she abused
herself and the way she have used the
world that's not who she is and so the
goal of eobard Thon is to grab Iris West
take her to the 25th Century and Jog her
memory to wake her up and that's the
cool thing here because Barry Allen
shows up to the house right like once
the whole battle with Multiplex is done
once it's all said and done once he has
this conversation with Hal Jordan Hal
Jordan's says look man do not be afraid
of what will happen do not be afraid of
the idea that Iris West will leave you
if you tell her who you are be honest be
open with her uh when it gets back home
to basically make that declaration and
say I Barry Allen and the Flash he ends
up being met with Wally West who's just
been totally decimated you know and of
course iparathon left a note inviting
Barry to the 25th Century but jumping
back to the 25th Century proper the
whole idea of of ear barthon is to say
I'm going to wake you up I'm going to to
awaken you to the way things really are
I'm going to take these memories that
are suppressed or whatever the case may
be and I'm going to show you who you
really are and so what seems to be
happening or what seems to seems like it
will happen is it Iris West remember
everything before the new 52. she'll
remember everything in classic DC she'll
remember the first time she ever met
Barry Allen and fell in love more so
than that she'll also remember when she
married Barry and when eobarthon went
back in time and killed her with that
being said guys if we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to Comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button become part of the Rob
Corps if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like ah this was
amazing but uh yeah I will catch you all
later
peace